patrick navès bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors dans
quelles conditions les discothèques vont
rouvrir on ne le sait pas encore
une date plus ou moins début juillet ce
que vous êtes soulagés par ces annonces
d'olivier veyrat soulagé oui non en fait
il ya du flou et des choses trop précise
le président de la république reçoit
certains professionnels le 21 à l'elysée
et fera des annonces plus circonstanciée
actuellement sur l'on sait c'est qu'on
nous parle de conditions spécifiques et
nous savons très bien par mo entretien
que ce soit avait il ya deux jours
encore à matignon que ce soit nous
entretient avec bercy et qui nourrit un
dialogue avec nous très précis on sait
très bien que est à l'ordre du jour lors
de l'imposition d'un pass sanitaire et
l'imposition des mains sanitaires et
pour nous quelque chose qui est
impossible au niveau de nos
établissements et leurs voix allez-y
plaisir et pourquoi pas solitaire est
impossible impasse élite et acessoires
premièrement un parcours vaccinale
complet par conte vaccinale complet il
ya 30 % des jeunes qui sont contre le
vaccin
au jour d'aujourd'hui il ya un peu plus
de 6% des moins de 29 vols qui sont
vaccinées vous voyez ça nous fûmes qu'un
tel crime qui très réduit deuxièmement
le passe à lithaire ça peut être aussi
un test sans piqué ni négatif mais il
doit de moins de 48 heures un test ainsi
génique négatif de -2 48 heures ça veut
dire que quelqu'un qui va en discothèque
un dimanche soir de faire le test
antigénique en matinée du samedi 20
journées du samedi le verser sur son
d'implication tout son petit quizz de
façon à faire enregistrer qui va faire
ça hein ça me dit comment ça va être
enregistrés voir et les exploitent les
clients qui sont en vacances
est-ce qu'ils vont devoir se promener
avec un coton-tige tout au long des
vacances pour tous les deux jours se
refaire un test pcr
c'est absolument impossible donc c'est
un gros problème pour nous les
conditions de mise en oeuvre
troisièmement la troisième fois qu'un
culte et je la vis pour mémoire ce sont
ceux qui ont eu la peau vide et qui doit
avoir un test anti génie positive depuis
quinze jours et de -2 6 - pour montrer
qu'ils sont rétablis on ça ça pose pas
de problème mais le gros problème c'est
qu'on n'a pas prévu les tests salivaires
où les autotests qui eux sont à la
culture de jeunes donc nous nous
souhaitions qu' un pas salutaire mais
avec photos de test et s et salivaires
possible cette option là a été écarté à
priori et on est parti sur les
recommandations qu'on fait curieusement
d'ailleurs les hôteliers et
restaurateurs qui ont dû imposer le
passe à lithaire audiothèque tu sais ce
qui est en train de se produire
et ça ça m'inquiète beaucoup j'attends
du président le 21 des positions à cet
égard je note d'ailleurs que il veut
sûrement envoyer un message fort à la
jeunesse est un message fort à une
profession qui est dans une position
tout à fait intenable et dramatique
après 16 mois de fermeture totale et
sans recettes
donc je voudrais qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout de cette logique d'espoir et que ce
pass sanitaires soient assorties de la
faculté de tests salivaires d'autotest
qui permettrait d'être mis en oeuvre ni
souhaitait alors sanitaire mais on parle
également aussi du port du masque de
l'âge d'ouverture
c'est ça aussi ça va risque d'être
compliqué l'huile est tous des
conditions parce que même s'il n'ya pas
solitaire
vous imaginez à l'entrée d'une
bibliothèque avec son application
consentent picauville l'exploitant doit
aller sur le feuillet vérification
demandé à chaque client son propre 1 sa
propre description surtout son pic au
bide l'a vérifié le faire en club ça
fait trois quatre minutes ça fait 8 à 10
clients par heure que l'on peut faire
entrer donc c'est un problème pratique
surtout quand on a d'autres éléments à
vérifier rentrée xo tech la tenue l'état
d'ébriété
etc etc donc on réussit à voir devant
l'entrée des établissements une joyeuse
pagaille et compris sur la chaussée
public et beaucoup de problèmes parce
que si on refuse un et qu'on accepte
l'autre c'est ma femme c'est mon
compagnon c'est mon ami etc
ils rentrent avec moi mais non et voilà
vous voyez ça est une question
absolument terrible alors les autres
contraintes que vous souteniez très
justement on ne sait pas si le port du
masque est obligatoire tout au long de
la soirée et c'est à dire quand vous
êtes assis peut-être l'enlever quand
vous vous levez le mettre sur la piste
de danse on ne sait pas actuellement à
l'heure où je vous parle je suis
incapable de vous dire si sur la piste
de danse
le match sera obligatoire ou non donc
c'est quand même une éco luc est très
importante la change la chose serait
fixée entre à 65%
c'est ce qui est fait dans les lieux de
spectacles et divertissements
actuellement je ne vois pas pourquoi il
y aurait une exception pour les
discothèques
nous mettrions parfaitement la jauge à
cet étiage là d'autant plus que comme ça
a été fait pour les hôtels restaurants
vraisemblablement le reste sympa 65%
si les choses se passent bien et passera
très vite à 80%
chose c'est un faux problème et en plus
je sais ça nous permettra de gérer la
promiscuité et la proximité des gens
puisque si on prend une pierre de
clients un client sur trois ans - ça va
laisser des chasseurs en discothèque
on a des critères rigoureux pour
recevoir moins de clients que dans un
bar par exemple ça va pouvoir permettre
d'aérer de l'espace et et d'accroître
ainsi que des sanitaires alors dernière
question mais vraiment très rapidement
on sait que cette crise dure maintenant
depuis plus d'un an
ça fait plus d'un an que vous êtes fermé
l'impact est terrible
économiquement est-ce que l'été peut
encore sauver certaines discothèques
menaçait de mettre la clé sous la porte
je lis pas je n'y crois pas en termes
économiques genou propos nitoo je crois
que ça va permettre aux saisonniers
l'été
vous savez ces données n'étaient même
pas touché un centime depuis septembre
2019 donc la vivre deux ans sans toucher
un seul centime ckoi quasiment
impossible donc pour huit appareils de
moins l'été c'est la wii qui vivent
toute l'année pour eux ça peut être ou
et de sauvetage mais ce sera très limite
les grands établissements
l'établissement urbain et c'est à mon
avis préféreront rester fermés comme
l'immense majorité
j'ai eu hier les discothèques du
cotentin qui ont pris la décision de me
paraît ou est envoyé au vu de ce que
l'on fait actuellement du passé me taire
merci beaucoup
en tout cas patrick malvaes d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président du syndicat national
des discothèques et lieux de loisirs